Welcome to FOSSDA, the Free and Open
Source Stories Digital Archive.
I am Elisabetta Mori, an interviewer with
FOSSDA, and today I'll be talking to
John Maddog Hall.
We are recording on TheirStory.io, and I
am in Livorno, Italy, and Maddog is
in Amherst, New Hampshire in the US.
Maddog is currently the board chair of
the Linux Professional Institute, the co-founder and
senior advisor to Kaninos Lukos, the president
of Project Kawan, and the executive director
of Linux International.
He has been a programmer, system designer,
synthesis administrator, product manager, technical marketing manager,
educator, author, CEO, and consultant.
He has worked on many systems, both
proprietary and open, having concentrated on Unix
systems since 1980 and Linux systems since
1994.
When he first met Linus Torvalds, he
currently recognized the commercial importance of Linux
and free and open source software.
Welcome, Maddog.
Thank you for being here today.
Let's start with where and when you
were born.
Well, thank you very much for inviting
me to do this.
I'm very honored to give this talk.
I was born in Baltimore, Maryland in
1950, and that was a time where
we saw the white person's water fountain
and the black person's water fountain.
We saw the white person's lunch counter
and the black person's lunch counter.
We celebrated the Civil War because it
was a hundred years since that had
happened.
And of course, it was also five
years after the end of World War
II.
So we saw a lot of the
people who had been fighting during that
war that had come home and were
now living among us.
Can you describe your parents?
My parents were the mom and pop.
My father was an airplane mechanic.
My mother was basically a homemaker, but
she had also studied accounting.
And she would work from time to
time in jewelry stores or bakery shops
or things like that as a manager
of the store.
But most of the time she stayed
at home taking care of my brother,
who was seven years older than I
was, and myself and my father, of
course.
Do you have any siblings?
I have one brother who is seven
years older than I am, but that's
the only person who is a sibling.
He is still alive.
What was your family life like?
It was good.
Did you have any important influence on
you in your early life?
My father was a good influence on
me because he was very interested in
mechanical things and machinery.
He would subscribe to these magazines called
Popular Mechanics and Popular Science and Popular
Electronics.
And every month when they came, he
would read through them and I would
read through them.
I particularly like the Popular Electronics magazines.
And as I got older, I attended
a electronics shop in high school where
we built radios and TVs.
We would first have to take apart
old broken radios and TVs, the parts,
because they were very expensive.
And then we would design new radios
out of the parts that we had
scavenged.
So I learned a lot about electronics
from that.
And that was one of the reasons
why I wanted to become an electrician
when I went to university.
My father also worked in a toy
store.
And I was assigned the assembling of
parts, bicycles and things, particularly the things
that required instructions.
My reading instructions.
And he would typically give this to
me and I would read the instructions
and then assemble the components for him.
So you went to high school in
the mid-1960s.
And then what happened?
What did you, what's your choice after
high school?
Well, I applied and was accepted to
Drexel University.
It was a very good engineering school,
very well known.
And it was a private university, not
a public one, but its tuition rate
was relatively low for those days.
And I started studying to be an
electrical engineer.
The other thing about Drexel was that
it was a cooperative education school, which
meant that you would go to school
for six months and then you would
work for six months and then go
back to school for six months and
work for six months.
And the work was actually part of
your education.
Every time you finished a work cycle,
you would have to write a report
for the school about what you did
and what you learned and things like
that and how was the job.
And so I got a job at
Western Electric Corporation, which was a manufacturing
arm of the telephone company.
And we had, in our plant, we
had over 4,000 people working.
It was a very large plant.
We made all the wiring cable for
the telephone company at the time.
And that included the cable that went
underneath of the ocean, what we call
long lines, to carry voice signals, telephone
signals to Europe from the United States.
Large ships would come into the port
right beside our plant and we would
load these cables on large spools into
the hold of the ship.
And then the ship would go out
and start laying the cable across the
ocean.
So this was a very interesting place
for a young electrical engineering student to
learn about, in that time, how to
control these massive machines, the wiring cable
in the telephone company.
During my first co-op trip that I
was approached by one of the engineers
there and said, we have a correspondence
course in how to program this computer
called an IBM 1130.
And do you want to take this
course?
It is free.
So I said, sure, I'll take the
course and I would read the book
at night and then I would go
in and practice at night and on
the weekends programming this IBM 1130, which
they had in the engineering lab.
That computer only had 4,000 16-bit words
of memory.
It had a one half megabyte disk
drive, hard disk drive.
I'll say that again for people.
One half megabyte of disk space.
And it had a paper tape reader
and punch and a printer.
And I would program this on punch
cards and write programs to practice and
then later on programs to help out
the engineers in the facility with the
work that they were doing.
So what was and when was your
first program?
Well, like I said, this was 1969
on this IBM.
So I don't remember what the first
program was because I was reading this
book and it was taking us through
very simple programs into more complex programs.
But one of the programs that I
wrote before I left, before I graduated
from university was a course.
It's a program to do multiple regression
analysis on wire from relating the physical
characteristics of wire to the electrical characteristics
of wire.
So it was a very engineering-oriented scientific
program that I had to jam all
the data that I needed into this
very small memory.
The IBM 1130 did not really have
an operating system.
When you wrote your program, you linked
the device drivers into your program, not
into the operating system.
You booted your program to run on
the computer and you could watch the
lights on the front of the panel
to see how your program was going
along.
And I could actually look after a
while, I could look at the lights
on the front panel and figure out
whether my program was in an infinite
loop or whether my program was proceeding
like it should be proceeding.
And it was a very interesting thing.
But of course, for a large portion
of this time, I was still an
electrical engineering student.
About halfway through my college education, I
was doing more and more computing and
less and less electrical engineering.
So I made a choice to switch
my curriculum to one that was half
engineering and business.
And so because I had done most
of my engineering work, I then started
studying accounting and marketing and management and
things like that, as well as having
my courses in physics and statistical analysis
and things like that.
So I really had a basis of
both sides of the world, the technical
side and the business side, when I
graduated with my degree in 1973.
And so in 1973, you worked at
Aetna Life and Casualty in Hartford, Connecticut.
Then you had another IBM computer, but
this time was a 360, 370, right?
Well, let's go back slightly back to
Drexel for a moment, because as I
started to get into computers, I found
out that there was this laboratory at
Drexel where they had digital PDP computers,
PDP8s and Link8s and things like that.
And again, this was a case where
I wasn't actually taking a course in
how to program these, but I was
learning this on my own.
I would be given a book on
how to program in assembly language, and
I taught myself how to do that.
I taught myself binary arithmetic by reading
books and then practicing.
And I started the Drexel Computer Club
while I was there.
I created a computer club.
We got together and we shared ideas
and thoughts and things.
And so when I said my degree
was in commerce and engineering, there was
a very strong minor in this thing
called data processing.
It wasn't computer science back in those
days.
It was more like computer black magic.
And so you got, you know, in
fact, I had a professor tell me
from Drexel, tell me, "John, you will
never be able to have a job
as a professional programmer." Because back in
those days, there were very few professional
programmers.
When you wrote a program, it's because
you were a physicist and you needed
the program for your physics.
You were an electrical engineer and you
needed the program for your electronics.
You were a chemist and you needed
the program for your chemistry.
You were an educator and you needed
this program to help you with your
education.
Very, very few people had a job
description of programmer.
So, you know, we had a minor
in programming.
And that's what I graduated with.
So then I got my job with
Aetna and Aetna was the world's company
in the world.
They were huge.
They had a building that was two
city blocks long, eight stories tall.
And it had a huge data center
that was four levels below the ground
and four levels above.
And they automatically ordered two of everything
that IBM announced, whether it was a
new tape drive or new mainframe.
IBM announced it.
Aetna ordered two.
And one went to our research division
to figure out how we were going
to use it.
And the other one went to the
computer floor because we knew we were
going to use it sooner or later.
And when they hired me, they saw
that I had taught myself machine language
programming for the PDP-8.
And they said, "do you think you
could learn machine language programming for the
IBM?" And I rather brashly said, "well,
do you have a book?" And they
thought that the world of that answer.
So they hired me for the job.
And I worked for them from 1973
to 1977, doing mostly machine language, assembly
language programming for IBM systems.
And during the same years, you also
got a master in computer science earned
at night.
Yes.
There was a huge number of insurance
companies in Hartford, Connecticut, the Hartford Travelers.
They all competed with each other, but
they all realized that they needed certain
things in common.
And so they got together and went
to the Rensselaer Polytechnic Institute in Troy,
New York and said to have our
computer people trained more in computer science
and how do you actively write programs
for these computers.
And we want you to open up
a branch of RPI in Hartford called
the Hartford Graduate School.
And the only course you're going to
teach is a master's degree in computer
science.
And RPI agreed to that.
And because they knew that all of
these insurance companies would be sending their
computer people to get their master's degree
at this graduate center.
So there will be a huge influx
of students to be trained.
And I went there starting in nineteen
seventy five, maybe seventy four.
And it took me three years at
night to get my master's degree in
computer science.
And I graduated in 1977.
So I would I would go there
two nights a week, study.
But in reality, I did all my
programming on Aetna's computers because the Hartford
Graduate Center only had a remote job
entry link to their computers in Troy,
New York.
But Aetna had all of this computing
power that at night was available to
me to do my programming jobs.
So that was that was no.
And what I learned in that wasn't
so much I learned a lot from
the courses themselves, but it reinforced what
I had learned from working on my
job and doing that type of work.
Back in those days, relational databases were
just starting to be used.
And Aetna was very much a user
of these type of databases.
James Martin, come in and talk to
us directly about the use of databases.
We had Ed Jordan, who and Larry
Constantine, who did structured programming, invented structured
programming.
They came and talked to us about
structured programming and saw the beginnings of
software engineering.
So these were very heady days.
And Aetna being so big and so
powerful.
They demanded the source code for the
operating systems from IBM.
If Aetna bought any software, they demanded
the source code of that software to
be put in escrow just in case
that company would go out of business.
So, you know, if you want to
sell something to Aetna, you had to
be willing to put your source code
into escrow, in case something happened.
And back in those days, when you
bought a software package, like maybe a
new compiler, you might pay one hundred
thousand dollars for that compiler to go
in one system used by one person
at a time.
And you would negotiate that contract for
months.
I should also say that in those
days, you could not apply software copyright
or software, you could not apply copyright
or patents to software.
That did not happen until the mid
1980s.
And consequently, the protection of software in
those days was done either by trade
secrets or by software contract.
And that contract was negotiated between you
and the company and might take months
to do.
So we paid one hundred thousand dollars
for one compiler to go on one
system and use it one person at
a time.
And when we bought that compiler, this
magnetic tape showed up with an engineer
attached to it.
That engineer would spend a week at
our facility trying to get their software
to work properly on our system.
And then they would run some tests
to show us it was working properly.
And then the engineer would say, "OK,
I'm going to take my tape back
to my company." And we would say,
no, you're going to take that tape
and put that in a safe in
escrow just in case your miserable little
company goes out of business.
We're Aetna and you're not.
Go ahead.
No, no, no.
To give you a better idea, we
had five hundred thousand magnetic tapes, 12
inch magnetic tapes in our tape library
on site with another one hundred thousand
tapes in software storage in a salt
mine in Idaho.
We had, I worked personally on a
file, one file of one program on
one system that had five hundred IBM
thirty three thirty disk drives hooked up
to it.
And each one of those thirty three
thirty disk drives cost thirty two thousand
US dollars in nineteen seventy five.
I had to write the disk driver
for it because IBM had no disk
driver that could support that many disk
drives at one time.
And IBM had to give us the
source code for their operating systems because
that's the only way we would do
business with them.
So what happened when what brought you
to move from Aetna to to have
your teaching experience at the Hartford State
Technical College?
Well, well, first of all, I had
always wanted to teach, told the supervisor
at Etna many times and I got
my degree in 1970.
My supervisor came over to me and
with a newspaper and said, "John, look
at this." There's an advertisement for a
professor at this little state technical college
that was very close to where Etna
was.
He said, "I know you've always wanted
to teach.
Why don't you take a look at
this technical college and see if you
if it's interesting to you." So I
took the day off of work.
I went over to the technical and
I didn't apply to the office.
I didn't take my resume into them
immediately.
Instead, I just wandered around the computer
science part of the college and talked
with some of the students.
I got the college catalog, which talked
about the courses they had.
I looked at the equipment which they
had in their computer lab.
And back in those days, every other
single state technical college in the state
of Connecticut would have an RJD link
to the University of Connecticut.
And they would punch cards.
This college had a PDP 1170 from
DEC that ran a time sharing operating
system called Vistas E.
It had 13 terminals in the computer
lab.
It had a separate digital PDP 1134
single user computer with a graphics tube
and a light pen.
It had a flatbed plotter for people
to plot out designs and things.
And I looked at the program.
I looked at the computer system.
I talked with the students and I
liked all of them.
So I then applied for the job
of a teacher there at the school.
And they accepted my resume.
I then went back to Aetna and
told my boss, thank you very much.
I I decided to leave Aetna and
go teach.
I had to take a $3,000 cut
in pay to go teach at the
school.
And of course, the teaching at the
school for that amount of money meant
I was teaching nine months of the
year.
If I taught at night, if I
taught during this course salary, but I
did eventually take a cut in pay
to go teach.
But it was a wonderful three and
a half years teaching at that school.
And I'm still in touch with many
of the students that I taught at
at that school.
Some of them didn't receive any more
formal education than what they got at
Hartford State Technical College.
We took, you know, in those days,
most of the students had never seen
a computer in real life.
They saw them on TV.
They saw them if they went with
their parents to, you know, at work.
But there were no computers in the
home.
There were very few computers in high
schools that when they came and put
their hands on the keyboard in my
lab was the first time they'd actually
touched a computer keyboard.
And from that in two years, we
took them to the point where they
could program in several different high level
languages, at least one assembly language.
And they also knew how to program
a database, a simple operating system and
a simple compiler.
So I was very proud of the
program.
I'm not, I don't take credit for
the program.
It was set up by the professor
in front of me, a person by
the name of Graham Buntz.
But Graham had to leave the school
because of health problems.
And I took over.
I was very soon I was made
the department head of the program.
And I stayed being the department head
until I left in 1977.
Where does your nickname "Maddog" come from?
I was afraid you were going to
ask that.
I'll try and tell this as quickly
as possible.
While I was teaching there at the
school, I sometimes got into arguments with
the dean of instruction about the proper
way of teaching students.
And sometimes these arguments would get very
heated, very hot.
And sometimes they were too hot for
bad dogs and Englishmen.
After the old Noel Cowell play, the
dean was British and then I was
the mad dog.
And I know people looking at me
today say, oh, mad dog, you're really
nice.
You're kind.
You tell great stories and stuff.
How did you get that name?
But they didn't know me at that
time.
I was 27 years old and I
had this very bad temper that sometimes
I would open up and people would
see it.
And I still have the temper.
But what I found out was that
if you lose your temper, you lose
the argument.
And so now my strategy is that
I make other people lose their temper.
And it works.
It's worked several times that I have
won an argument by making other people
lose their temper.
So you stayed in school for three
years.
And then what changed?
What happened?
Well, a couple of things happened.
Quite frankly, I was spending more money
than I made.
I was going deeper into debt and
I didn't see any real path out
of that.
And I had a student who graduated
in the electrical engineering part, electrical technology
part of the school, that he had
gotten a job at Bell Laboratories in
Massachusetts.
And he said to me, "Maddog, they're
looking for a UNIX systems administrator there.
Why don't you actually they're looking for
an administrator there, systems administrator there.
Why don't you apply?" Now, that other
than my mother and my father, every
single person in my family, my grandmother,
my aunt, my aunt's husband, my brother,
my sister-in-law, and I, of course, worked
for Wester Electric.
So working for the telephone company was
something that was in my blood.
And to go to work for Bell
Laboratories, who had this huge reputation in
the scientific research field, was was very,
very tempting.
So I went up to the Bell
Labs facility.
I I started the interviewing process and
they said, "we want you to be
the systems administrator of a cyber 720
computer system." Now, there's a lot of
people who think that UNIX is unfriendly.
Well, the CDC cyber knew there were
users out there and it hated them.
And so it was a very complex
operating system that, you know, there were
very few of them around.
And I looked at this and I
said, "no, I don't really want to
be the systems administrator for the cyber.
I want to be the systems administrator
for your UNIX systems." And they said,
"well, we already have two people doing
that job and we don't really, you
know, we don't think that we want
you to be the systems administrator of
the cyber." And I said, "I'm sorry,
if you don't want me to be
the systems administrator of the UNIX systems,
then I don't want to work for
you." And it was like shock on
their faces that somebody had told them
that they didn't want to work for
Bell Laboratories.
But I knew that Bell Laboratories had
developed UNIX and I knew that if
I was going to be a systems
administrator, I would have access to everything
that was in UNIX.
And that's what I wanted to be.
I could see a future for UNIX,
but I did not see a future
for Cyber 720 and the NOS operating
system.
So I went back to the school.
I was back there about a week.
Bell Labs called me up again.
They said, "Mr.
Hall, we're going to have we're going
to buy a contract from CDC, but
we want you to be the systems
administrator of the UNIX system.
Have you ever used UNIX before?" "No.
But do you have a book about
it?" And so between the time I
accepted the job and read, I read
a lot about UNIX.
And when I went there, they sent
me to a UNIX class for a
week.
And then I became the UNIX systems
administrator.
And I stayed there for three and
a half years before I had a
job offer from Digital Equipment Corporation.
Where was the job for Digital Equipment?
Which city?
Well, it was very close because Digital
had a headquarters in Maynard, Massachusetts, and
Bell Labs was in North Andover, Massachusetts.
I then, you know, these were development
part of actually in Maryland, I'm sure,
and they were building a new facility
in Nashua, New Hampshire, which is very
close to where I live.
So for the first couple of months,
I lived in my house in Massachusetts
and then worked in New Hampshire.
But then I moved into an apartment
in New Hampshire and stayed there for
a number of years.
So it was very close to where
I was.
But Digital was starting up a new
UNIX group and they were going to
be developing their own version of UNIX.
And so I was, of course, very
interested in doing this.
And that's where I joined.
I joined Digital to do that work.
And so you started working for Digital
Equipment Corporation in 1983.
So there is something that at some
point happens in 1994.
So what was that?
OK, so when we start, when I
started working for Digital in 1983, at
that point, a lot of different companies
were dabbling in UNIX.
They weren't really happy about UNIX because
they had their own proprietary operating systems.
You know, IBM had MVS and VMCMS
and Hewlett Packard had MPE as their
operating system.
And Digital, of course, had VMS, their
pride and joy of the VAX system.
And they had a wide range of
different operating systems on the PDP-11.
They had VistaC, which I was familiar
with.
They had RT-11, which I was familiar
They had various different types of UNIX
systems.
But what happened was this company called
Sun Microsystems decided that they were going
to bring out a system that that
was specifically for UNIX at a much
lower price than you could buy a
VAX computer system or something from Hewlett
Packard.
And they were looking for an operating
system to put on it.
They had even come to Digital and
asked to license VMS, but that wouldn't
happen.
And so they chose UNIX and specifically
the Berkeley Software Distribution from the University
of California, Berkeley.
So originally, if you wanted UNIX on
your system, you first had to buy
a source code license from AT&T.
And if you were not a university,
that could be extremely expensive.
And you had to supply AT&T the
serial number of your computer system that
you were going to put the source
code on.
And if that system broke and you
wanted to put another system, you had
to call up AT&T, give them the
next serial number before you could move
the code to the next computer.
So this is very awkward, very difficult.
Universities had a site-wide source code license.
And when I say universities, I'm talking
about research universities like Stanford, like Berkeley,
like Caltech, like MIT.
If you were Hartford State Technical College,
you didn't get that type of license.
You had to pay the huge amount
of money.
So with Sun, they went back to
AT&T and they said, "we're going to
distribute our code only in binary form.
Does that make a difference?" And AT&T
said, "yes, we will give you a
much, much cheaper license.
You know, you won't have to give
us a serial number.
You'll be able to manufacture this and
put this out, you know, for a
very low price." And this woke up
all these other computer companies like DEC,
like Hewlett Packard, like IBM and said,
oh, we have to have the same
deal.
We have to come out with our
own version of Unix in binary only
form so we can get the same
type of deal from AT&T.
And that is when Digital hired me
as one of at that time, I
think there were only 16 people in
the whole engineering group.
We eventually grew to be over 500.
And, you know, to bring out this
version, this binary only version of Unix.
And this is important because as we
get to Mr.
Stallman in a little bit, we'll see
why this affected him.
I was in Digital.
We brought out several different versions of
something we called V7M11.
That was version 7M modified.
We brought that out.
We eventually changed that name to Ultrix
11.
We had another system, Ultrix 32 for
the VAX.
And that was going along.
After a number of years, we came
out with this processor called the Alpha,
the DEC Alpha.
This was the this ended up being
the fastest microprocessor in the world for
eight years.
It was also a 64 bit system
instead of 32 bit.
Now, why is that important?
It's important because with 32 bits, you
can access four billion bytes of data.
But with 64 bits, you can access
four billion times four billion bytes of
data.
And that's enough to store about 32
bytes of data for every square millimeter
on the surface of the earth, including
all the oceans.
It is a huge amount of data.
And at the same time, we appointed
this new operating system called OSF-1 that
was developed by the Open Software Foundation
onto the Alpha to make a new
distribution of Unix for the Alpha computer.
So we were starting to put this
out.
This, of course, was a closed source
proprietary system that you still needed an
AT&T source code license to get.
You needed to, you know, it was
it was very expensive to get the
source code for it.
And I was sitting there by this
time being in technical marketing thinking, how
can we make this code available to
researchers, university researchers in how to use
this very large address space?
Because in order for them to get
the source code for OSF-1, they had
to spend a lot of money.
They had to.
And then when they finished their research,
how did they publish it?
You know, all they can do is
write white papers about it.
And, you know, so I was looking
for a platform that university people could
do the research and then publish not
only their white papers, but also the
source code for the work they had
done freely without having to worry about
copyright or anything like that.
And at the same time, I had
a friend of mine who was looking
to bring this person from Europe to
a DECAS group in New Orleans, Louisiana,
where we were going to have our
DECAS membership meeting.
Now DECAS, I had been familiar with
in the university.
I had gotten a lot of my
software from DECAS because it was free
software that you could just order from
my catalog for like five US dollars.
Remember, I told you about the one
compiler that was $100,000?
I could get a compiler written by
a DECAS member for five US dollars.
They basically pay for the cost of
the paper tape to be sent through
the postal mail to me.
I was exposed to DECAS at the
university, exposed to DECAS at Harper State
Technical College, out of my software for
my students.
I was exposed to DECAS at Bell
Labs because even though we were using
AT&T's UNIX system, we were using it
on DeX hardware, the VAX 11780.
So I was exposed to DECAS this
whole time, which were users of digital
equipment who wrote software and contributed it
to the DECAS library so that other
people could be helped by it.
And so I was going to this
DECAS meeting.
There were 19,000 people going to be
coming to the meeting.
I said, OK, I will finance this
young person from Europe to come to
DECAS to talk about the software that
he wrote, whatever it is.
And when I arrived at DECAS in
New Orleans, I saw Linux for the
first time because this young person was
Linus Torvalds, who I'd never heard of
before.
I'd never heard of Linux before.
They invited me to use Linux.
And I said, this is really good.
And this was on an Intel system.
This is really good.
And I listened to Linus' talks.
Only 40 people showed up to each
talk, which today it would be 6,000
people who would show up to hear
him talk.
But only 40 people out of 19,000
showed up.
And after he gave his talk, I
took him out on this riverboat called
the Natchez.
And while on board the Natchez, I
said to him, "Linus, have you ever
thought about making Linux 64-bit and putting
it on a RISC processor instead of
an Intel CISC processor?" And he said,
"well, I'd like to do that.
But the DEC office in Helsinki, Finland
has been having problems getting me an
alpha.
So I may have to do an
IBM PowerPC instead." Now, I knew this
was a wrong answer.
I knew the alpha system was really
the one he wanted to do.
And so I said, don't do anything
rash.
I went back to digital headquarters and
I called up a friend of mine
named Jim Jackson.
Now, for your audience, people would tell
you that the way you get things
done in a big company is that
you write a proposal.
You send it to your management.
They look at it.
They send it to their management.
It goes up.
This could take work.
And so I did the thing that
you really get stuff done.
I called in favors.
And I'd been working at digital at
that point for 11 years.
And there were a lot of people
who owed me favors.
And Jim Jackson was one of them.
And I said, hi, Jim.
You don't know who this person is.
You don't know what he did.
But I need to have an alpha
system sent to Helsinki, Finland right away.
He said, you're in luck.
I have one sitting beside my desk
that was returned from a software developer.
To make a long story short, that
system was worth 30,000 U.S.
dollars.
And Jim Jackson sent it to this
person he never heard of with no
justification whatsoever other than Mad Dog said
it should go.
And Jim says, "what are you going
to pay for?" I said, "I'll pay
for the shipping." And that showed up
in Linus' doorstep one day before the
IBM PowerPC.
But by that time, Linus had made
up his mind that the alpha was
the one he really wanted to do.
And so when the IBM PowerPC showed
up, he basically never even turned it
on.
And he didn't turn it on for
over a year.
Finally, he did turn it on just
so he could tell IBM he had
turned it on.
But I then gathered some people at
Digital who were also interested in having
this research project done for the alpha.
And they helped out with some of
the low-level engineering that had to be
done.
While Linus and the rest of the
kernel developers worked on the higher-level parts
of the kernel, getting that working on
the system.
And we finished the port.
We started the port in earnest on
January the 1st of 1995.
And we finished the port in November
with the release of Red Hat software
in November of 1995.
So 11 months to take Linux from
being a 32-bit kernel only on Intel
systems to being a big kernel.
And on N architectures, not just two.
So in other words, if you wanted
to add PowerPC, if you wanted to
add Motorola, Linus set up the Swoyskio
tree to cover all of those architectures.
So this was a major step in
the Linux kernel.
And it's one of the reasons why
the Linux kernel is used as part
of Android as well as GNU Linux.
Go ahead.
No, no..
go ahead.
So this is how I got this
is why I got interested in Linux.
And I could see because by this
time I'd been in the computer industry
a long time.
And I could see the rate at
which Linux was growing.
And I could see that Unix systems
were really losing out to Windows NT.
Because by this time, Microsoft was not
only being satisfied with the desktop, they
wanted server systems also.
And while Unix systems were still the
king of a server system environment, along
with proprietary operating systems like MVS, VMS,
and MFT and others.
The you know, you could see that
Windows NT was beginning to encroach on
that.
Or Riley, who had been, you know,
spent years publishing books on Unix and
books on Unix applications was now switching
over to publishing books on Windows NT.
And I don't blame Tim for doing
that because he had a publishing house,
he had people he employed and stuff.
But I felt a little bit betrayed
by the person who had been pushing
these Unix books for years, and was
now falling into the Microsoft camp.
But as Linux came out, he switched
back.
He stopped publishing books on Windows NT
and went back to repurposing his books
on Unix to this new thing called
Linux.
And of course, he started up the
conference, the open source conference every year,
and he's been active in the open
source work.
But I find it interesting that he
did make that switch, you know, in
the midst.
And I knew that Linux was going
to reinvigorate the Unix marketplace.
It was going to supply Unix like
systems in all spaces.
And today, Linux is the most used
operating system in the world.
If you combine Android, if you say
all the embedded systems that are being
produced that use Linux, if you say
all the service systems that are Linux
server systems, particularly in the cloud, if
you say that all 500 of the
fastest supercomputers in the world use Linux,
Linux is the most used kernel in
the world.
And, you know, that I was very
happy about that.
And I'm very happy about the fact
that Linux is not only open source
software, but is free software that uses
a GPL license, not one of the
other open source licenses.
Can you describe Linus Torvalds and your
relationship with him?
It is a strange relationship because I
knew Linus, you know, first as this
university student who had this project.
I was amazed by the project, quite
frankly.
Now, I've seen other open source projects
like the X-Windows system from MIT, like
the Berkeley software distribution of BSD Unix.
I've seen those, but those were all
places that had a central focal point.
You know, the X-Windows system had the
X consortium that came out of Boston
or came out of Cambridge, Massachusetts.
And Berkeley, of course, had the University
of California Berkeley.
Linux was a thing that the center
of the Linux project was Linus's bedroom
in Helsinki, Finland.
And it was being developed by these
people who were scattered across the world
that many of them had never met
each other face to face.
And over the years, I started to
think more about this and why this
happened at this time.
And I came up with three major
things.
Number one, Linus first started the project
because he had a brand new 386
processor that he had gotten for Christmas.
And, of course, the operating system that
came with it was Microsoft.
And Microsoft at the time used a
swapping type of memory system, which meant
that the largest program you could possibly
have in your Microsoft system was how
much you had.
And your whole program had to fit
into that RAM, possibly extended a little
bit by what we call overlays.
But that was a limitation.
That was the operating system, not the
hardware.
The 386 could support what we call
demand page virtual memory, which will allow
you to have a program as big
as a disk drive that backed it
up.
And so this was a real limitation
on the Microsoft operating system of the
time.
The second thing was that the Internet
was actually coming into your home.
The Internet existed in universities, existed in
companies.
But in 1994, you could actually get
the Internet through DSL or through beings
in your house.
And therefore, people could work on this
project, not at their office, not at
the university, but in their homes.
And the third thing was that there
was already existing a wide range of
documentation about how operating systems were supposed
to work.
There were things like Minix, which was
a microkernel that that leaders did for
one reason or another didn't choose.
There were there was BSD that you
could get the source code for.
But, you know, that was tied up
with some type of legal things from
AT&T.
And so all these things came together,
the documentation, the Internet in the home,
and the availability of this very powerful
386 processor that could have demand page
virtual memory.
And then finally, this very stubborn young
man in Helsinki, Finland, who was going
to write his own kernel just for
fun.
It wasn't going to be a big
important project.
It was just going to be his
little hobby.
Does anybody want to join him with
us with this?
And so I met him.
So he started the project in 1991.
Version one of the kernel had come
out just a month or so before
I met him at this event.
And if you if you work with
operating system development, you realize that version
one is the first version that people
say, OK, we can really have people
using this.
It has enough functionality that is useful
to the average person.
Before that, you have version zero point
one, version zero point two, version zero
point three.
And for the previous year, Linux had
been on version point nine nine nine
nine point nine nine nine nine nine
nine nine and point nine nine nine
nine nine nine nine.
Until finally, in the first few months
of 1994, it became version one.
In the meantime, in 1993, there were
these other groups of people like Yggdrasil,
soft landing systems, a fledgling red hat
and others who were taking the kernel
and all the new tools and some
of the things from BSD and putting
them together into distributions.
So their distributions were either Debian was
already also there.
The distributions were already shipping or very
close to shipping when Linus said, OK,
it's one dot oh.
And so they put the one dot
oh kernel into their distributions.
And that's when Linux hit the big
time.
OK, so I'm seeing it because Linux
with version one dot oh of the
kernel on top of this Intel system
that was 32 bit.
And I'm saying, I want to see
this when an alpha 64 bit system
with the fastest microprocessor in the world.
And so I met Linus.
He's a very quiet, you know, introspective
type of person.
And I liked him immediately, not just
because he had done Linux, but because
I liked him.
And he liked me.
And we went out on this riverboat
I talked about.
I took it and showed him the
steam engine at the part of at
the back of the boat.
I didn't know at that time that
he loved steam engines.
He is a math physics major and
he loved the whole concept of steam
engines.
So here I am explaining the steam
engine to him and how it works,
because I love steam engines.
I also like mechanical clocks.
I didn't realize at the time that
he likes mechanical clocks.
I like warm puppies.
He loves warm puppies.
And eventually I met his wife, Tuve,
who prefers to be called Susan these
days.
And so eventually one day they called
me up and they said, "Maddog, we're
about to have a child.
Would Would you like to be one
of the godfathers?" So each finished person,
each finished child has two godfathers and
two godmothers.
And Linus and Tuve would be to
be one of the godfathers.
Dirk Hondo is the other godfather.
And then two godmothers.
And I accepted and I went over
for the baby naming ceremony, which was
about six months after Patricia was born.
And I met all their family and
stuff.
So, you know, this is not about
Linux or about computers.
It's about I like them and they
seem to like me.
And I some from time to time
visit them in the house.
And people say to me, oh, Mad
Dog, you must talk to Linus a
lot about Linux.
I say, no, I don't.
There was enough people who give him
advice and knowledge stuff on Linux.
I talked to him about his family
and his interests other than Linux.
And I think that's why they also
continue to like me.
So let's go back to 1994.
So in 1994, you began your experience
with Linux International.
So can you explain to us what
is Linux International and what are your
major contributions to these so far?
OK, so in 1990, there was a
group of small companies who said Linux
is looked at by hobbyists and some
people in the scientific community.
But we really think that it has
commercial value.
And these companies were people like the
original Linux mall by Mark Bolstern.
Bill Hughes, who started the Linux Journal,
a very, very young Red Hat that
was started by Mark Ewing, Eric Trowen
and Donnie Barnes, and then later joined
by Bob Young, who became the president
of Red Hat.
We had people from Yggdrasil, eventually even
Sun Microsystems joined and Digital joined.
But because these companies were very small,
they didn't have much money to help
to fund Linux International.
And when I went to my boss
and said we can know digital can
join Linux International at the highest membership
rate, he said, "what is that rate?"
I said, "four thousand dollars." He said,
"I don't think I can write a
check for that small amount of money."
But he did.
And we joined.
And this was, you know, we started
it up and almost immediately we were
hit with a problem.
There was this person in Boston, Massachusetts,
who had trademarked the term Linux and
was contacting all these companies saying, "unless
you pay me a quarter of your
revenues, I'm going to sue you and
block you from using the word Linux."
Now, anybody who does licensing of trademarks
or technology of any type knows that
a quarter of your revenues is just
ridiculous.
And so almost immediately we knew that
this was not a serious thing.
We talked to Linus about it and
says, "Linus, did you ever be contacted
by this guy?" He says, "yes, he
calls me up." And the first thing
he says to me on the phone
is, "do you believe in God?" And
that's difficult with Linus because he doesn't.
And so we hired a lawyer, a
guy by the name of Jerry Davis,
who was, you know, he said he
would do this work pro bono, which
is very generous of him.
And another lawyer by the name of
Eric Bustani, who also worked with Jerry.
And we started investigating this and we
found out that this person in Boston
kept going through lawyers.
And every time we talked or tried
to talk to him, it was to
a different lawyer.
And we realized that this guy was
kind of bonkers.
So his final lawyer said to me,
"look, he doesn't really have a case
on this.
And if you just pay the money
which he has paid to register the
Linux trademark, he will transfer it to
somebody you want to, to do that,
you know, to hold it." So we
had him transfer it to Linus.
Linus now is the holder of the
Linux trademark.
And we have we set up a
method of protecting and licensing the term
Linux.
You have to do that.
You can't just put it into the
public domain.
It's very bad.
So people can license the term Linux
for any legitimate purpose, free of charge.
And we formulated a way of protecting
the Linux trademark legally.
We also started a project called the
Linux standard base.
We, that was to help people who
want to put binary applications and have
them run across distributions.
We started a marketing campaign.
Having the Linux Business Expo as part
of Comdex.
So this was using Linux in a
business case with business applications.
We formulated an event at CBIT, the
world's largest computer show for a number
of years.
We went there for 17 years as
Linux International and participated in the Linux
Pavilions at CBIT.
We did this type of work.
And of course, I started going around
the world talking about Linux, working with
governments and corporations to have them understand
about Linux and what it's going on.
So in particular, I wanted to ask
about your roles being a consultant for
governments.
I don't know what you can share
with us.
But if you could perhaps tell us
a little bit about how you were
consulted for open source software, open hardware
and in general free culture with the
example, so I am thinking about perhaps
China.
So when did you have contact with
China?
And if you can summarize, you know,
what was your role, what you achieved,
thinking also about Malaysia, Canada, Vietnam.
So we can provide examples and also
when it happened, which years.
Sometimes I get a little hazy on
the years, so don't hold my feet
to the fire on that.
Let's talk about Malaysia.
Malaysia, the Malaysian government was creating a
five year program to use open source
software.
And Malaysia is particularly interesting because unlike
a lot of other countries, at that
time, 70 percent of the people that
were in IT were women.
And 70 percent of managers in younger
managers were women.
And the reason for this was that
men in Malaysia at the age of
15 could typically go out and get
a job doing heavy labor, digging ditches
and running machinery and stuff like that.
But women would typically not do that.
So women would then go on to
university and they would get the education
and the skills to do data processing
and management.
And so the government of Malaysia had
this program at the time, had this
program to even this out and make
it 50-50 that 50 percent of the
people would be women and 50 percent
would be men.
And at this time, they were putting
together a program to train people and
stuff like that.
So they invited me over to talk
about free software and licensing and how
this could be done.
I never really got a good report
back on them as the success of
their program.
But I know that Malaysia for a
number of years was heavily stressing free
software in doing this.
So that was Malaysia.
China was about 1996 when I first
went over to China.
There was a distribution called Red Flag
Linux, which looked a lot like Red
Hat Linux.
I mean, very, very much like Red
Hat Linux, except that Red Flag Linux
was being sold to host offices and
other places by the government.
Eventually, Red Flag Linux was incorporated into
another distribution of Linux called Asiatic Linux,
which is used both by China, Japan
and South Korea as the Asiatic languages,
it stresses multi-byte codes like ISO codes
for letters.
And I first met with the Red
Flag people, and people, and then later
on I met with the Asiatic people
at various trade shows and things like
that.
I recently went to Cuba.
Cuba, as you know, has had an
embargo against it, which makes it very
difficult for them to use products from
Microsoft or things like that.
So they have refocused on using Linux.
They have their own distribution of Linux
called Nova.
And they are also very interested in
some of the newer technologies like RISC-V,
which would be spread across multiple countries
and stuff.
Let's see, what other ones are you
interested in?
Well, perhaps what you did for United
Nations.
Oh, well, I've gone to several different
United Nations things.
They had a thing called WIT4 that
was a joint thing between Germany and
the United Nations in in developing countries
and developing their technology and stuff.
And WIT4 was very in tune with
Linux and using open source software in
order to do that.
I attended several different conferences sponsored by
WIT4.
One of them was in Oman in
northern Africa.
One was in Vietnam.
So I would attend those and do
presentations and sit down with them and
talk about licensing and what licensing meant.
And the amount of money, the huge
amount of money that would be saved
by countries.
And instead of sending all of that
in license and royalty fees back to
the United States, they instead could take
that money and pay local programmers to
improve free software, which creates local jobs,
local housing, and pays local taxes.
And of course, that money comes back
to create a demand for local services
like programming, like systems administration, like creating
solutions for people, which could then generate
more jobs for programming.
So for every dollar that you send
outside of your country, it really represents
ten dollars if you kept it inside
your country.
And this is one of the things
I've been trying to tell people over
the years.
It's very strong, I think.
But we have another problem.
We can see this problem now with
some of the political things that are
going on.
And that's what happens when some country
decides that they're going to do something
and other countries say, well, we're going
to create an embargo against you.
And for many years, there were extremely
good programmers in Russia.
And Russia was one of the first
countries that really took Linux seriously.
Back in 1996, I think, I went
to Russia for the first time to
a Unix Expo, and they already had
Linux there.
And the programmers were really good.
But now, because of the Ukraine situation,
you have all these countries putting embargoes
on Russia.
And it's disrupting the flow of products
and things that Russians can use.
So I live in a very strange
country.
I love my country, the United States.
But, a lot of times in the
United States, we don't think about what
would happen if our access to computing
was turned off like that.
And so if you live outside of
the United States, you may have to
think twice about where are you going
to get your processors, your software, things
like that.
Another thing is, what would happen if
some type of nuclear holocaust was to
hit Redmond, Washington?
How long would it take Microsoft to
put together the engineering team to be
able to generate the next release of
Windows?
Even if they had the source code
for Windows scattered across the world, where
do they get the engineering talent, the
people that know that software?
With Linux, the source code is distributed
on servers all over the world.
And the people that know about it
or can know about it is spread
all over the world.
So from a geopolitical safety standpoint, you
have to look at that.
You have large countries like the United
States, like Russia, like China, which has
the people who could put together an
operating system and maintain it.
But then you have small countries like
Monaco or Liechtenstein.
They don't have a prayer of putting
together the amount of engineering power they
need.
So what they have to do is
cooperate with people from all over the
world.
And yet at the same time, they
have to be able to see the
source code so that they know that
these other countries are not putting Trojan
horses and things like that into it.
Microsoft, as an example, has places around
the world where you can go.
You have to leave your laptop outside,
your phone outside, your pencil and paper
outside.
They will allow you to look over
the Internet at code that they say
is the source code for Microsoft products.
Really?
How do you know?
And what is the product you're looking
at?
And are you sure that the code
you're looking at is actually the code
that went into the product that you
got from Microsoft?
And the answer is you don't know.
So all these things are things that
need to be looked at and need
to be thought about by leaders.
And this is the type of thing
I talk to them about.
So I would like to talk about
a few things, not too much extensively,
then we can move to another topic.
So first is your role in the
board as a board chair of the
Linux Professional Institute.
So if you can briefly say what
it is and what's your role there.
So the board of directors of any
organization is responsible for the fiscal and
legal actions of the organization itself to
make sure that in our case, we're
a membership organization.
Are we doing the proper things for
the members?
Are we handling the finances correctly?
Is the organization going to go into
bankruptcy?
Are we doing things in a legal
way that we're doing things in a
fair matter?
So as an example, one of the
things we did recently was a diversity
and inclusion policy for for our organization
because we have two hundred fifteen thousand
certified people in one hundred eighty countries
around the world.
That sounds great.
But on the other hand, are we
making sure that in these different countries
that women get equal representation, that gay
people get equal representation?
And we say when we say equal,
we mean that the membership of LPI
should reflect the population of these countries.
I mean, it'd be close to impossible
to get 16 percent of the population
of Africa to be black because there
aren't 16, 16 percent of say Africa,
Alaska, 16 percent.
There aren't 16 percent of the people
in Alaska who are black.
So to say that we're going to
have 16 percent of the programmers in
Alaska be black is kind of hard.
So on the other hand, if it's
in Africa and a large population, the
large percentage of that population is black,
then maybe we should be a little
suspect if 70 percent of the programmers
are white.
And so we should be working to
make the different populations that we are
responsible for match the populations of the
areas that we're in.
And likewise, the economic scale, we need
to make sure that as much as
possible, as much as we can influence,
that people are up and down the
pay scale matching the population.
Okay, so this is what we worked
into our policy.
And this is now a focal point
of what LPI is doing along with
the other things that we're trying to
do, which is create a professional aspect
to free and open source software programming
and administration.
Now, as the board chair, I'm responsible
for driving this, for making sure that
the board members have equal input to
these policies and things like that.
We're about to have our annual general
meeting in June, invite all of our
members to participate.
We're coming up with elections for the
new board.
And these are some of the things
that I have to make sure are
being done.
So in on June 24, 2012, you
wrote you actually published an article.
The title is in horror in honor
of Alan Turing, and that was on
Linux magazine.
Can you tell us more about this?
Yes, I am gay.
One of the nice things about the
computer industry is that they have been
relatively accepting of LGBTQ people from as
long back as I can remember.
I've mentioned DECA several times.
You would go to DECA's and they
would have special interest groups of LGBT
LGBTQ people.
The Eustics Association that's located in California
would have conferences and they would have
their groups, their local groups of LGBTQ
people join the first night of a
conference and tell people you're safe here.
You know, you can you can be
yourself here.
But I was still relatively closeted, not
because I felt that I would be
persecuted by being gay, but I just
felt no real need to talk about
it.
And my life is going along fine.
I I was perfectly happy, you know,
working for DECA, working at the school
with things.
And, you know, I just did.
If people had asked me, are you
gay?
I would have told them.
But there was no need to.
However, about the year 2000, people started
to talk about marriage equality.
Why can't gay people get married?
Why can't LGBTQ people get married?
And people started off with things like
civil unions.
But there was a lot of legal
problems with civil unions.
I have been the justice of the
peace in New Hampshire for the last
30 years, which means that I can
perform wedding ceremonies.
I can take two people and make
them husband and wife.
But I am just a witness of
this.
Basically, I lead them through.
I I am what is known as
an officiant.
And I recognize that it's the state
that controls marriage, not the church.
The church can give their blessing to
a marriage.
That's fine.
The church can be an officiant to
a marriage.
That's fine.
But unless you have a marriage license
from the state, you're not going to
be married.
And it's the state that controls things
like inheritance.
It's the state that controls things like
when you get divorced, who gets whatever.
So I started to follow this because
I am a justice of the peace.
And I started to see a lot
of hostility that I had never experienced
before of the general population being against
gay people.
And I started seeing young people being
thrown out of their house, being abandoned
by their families just because they are
gay.
And this started to make me angry.
And I started to participate in the
New Hampshire push to get marriage equality
in New Hampshire.
Now, other states had, like I said,
had civil unions.
California had a civil union.
Massachusetts had a civil union.
But then their court system forced them
to turn it from civil union into
marriage.
And in New Hampshire, we were the
first state not to have the justice,
not that the courts forced us to
do it, but instead have our legislature
vote to do it and our governors
sign it into law.
And I participated in pushing that.
But there was still a large portion
of the United States where kids were
still being thrown out of their house.
And I just I just couldn't take
that because, you know, when you're growing
up and you're fat and you're geekish
and you're bullied in school because you're
a geek, it's twice as bad when
you're also gay.
So if you're geek and gay, it's
really intolerable.
And five times the number of kids
go to suicide who are gay than
in the normal population.
For every kid in the normal population
that goes to suicide, five times the
number in the LGBTQ community.
And this is wrong.
And so I wrote that article for
all the geeky gay kids that are
out there to say, you know, it's
OK that you're gay.
It's OK that you're lesbian.
It's OK that you're trans.
It doesn't hurt me.
It doesn't hurt anybody else.
And if you know, I'm not telling
everybody to come out because you have
to make that in your own decision.
Your own time is something you have
to determine.
But I am telling you that sooner
or later it will get better.
And, you know, so I wrote that
article, I published that and I published
that because Alan Turing, considered to be
the father of computer science, the father
of artificial intelligence and who during World
War II saved an estimated 14 billion
lives and cut World War II short
by about two years, was himself gay,
was persecuted for it, and many people
say committed suicide in 1954.
I wish I could have met Alan
Turing.
I've been lucky enough to meet other
people like Grace Barry Hopper, who I
consider to be the first modern day
programmer, or Maurice Wilkes, who invented microcode
and subroutines.
I've met them.
I've met lots of people and I've
known lots more.
You know, like Hedy Lamarr, well-known actress,
but also the person who developed the
underpinnings for modern day Bluetooth, Wi-Fi, and
split-spectrum programming or split-spectrum technology.
So, you know, I admire these people.
And after I wrote that article, I
would go to a conference and I
would have young people walk up to
me and say thank you for writing
that article.
Thank you.
I'm just curious.
I will also say that 10 years
ago, I met somebody that we fell
in love and in 2017, I married
him.
He's now my husband and we're trying
to get him a permanent visa for
the United States.
He's actually Brazilian.
Sounds lovely.
Let's talk about Brazil.
So there is another Maddog, Maddogs in
Brazil.
I'm talking about Caninos Lucas, Mad Dogs.
So can you explain what it is
and how you became involved in it?
So in 1994, I'm sorry, it must
have been 1996.
In 1996, I went to Sao Paulo,
Brazil for the first time.
There was a free software conference down
there.
And, you know, so I often ask
people, what do you think about when
you think about Brazil?
You know, and people say, oh, soccer
or football, however you call it.
And they think about the Amazon and
the rainforest.
And they think about Samba and, you
know, all these different things.
They think about Piranha, you know, the
fish.
But they don't think about the fact
that Brazil is the 12th largest economy
in the world.
They don't think about the fact that
Sao Paulo is the second largest city
in the western hemisphere after only Mexico
City, with New York being far down
the line.
They don't think about the fact that
the University of Sao Paulo has 100,000
students and 16,000 PhDs.
It is the number one university in
all of Latin America.
They don't think about those things.
And so I got to know this.
I got to know some of the
faculty at the University of Sao Paulo,
and particularly somebody named Dr.
Marcelo Zufo.
And he showed me the first Beowulf
supercomputer that I'd ever seen in real
life.
I had seen pictures of them.
I had actually talked with people who
had made them.
But he was actually using one to
do really good research.
And I was very impressed by this.
And so I stayed in touch with
him.
And I started going to more and
more of these conferences, not only in
Brazil, but all over Latin America.
And I saw amazing things, things that
people in the United States would do.
And so eventually, about the time that
the Raspberry Pi came out, I had
met some of the board members of
the Raspberry Pi Foundation.
And I invited one of those to
come to Brazil to a large event
and see the types of things that
I had seen.
And he came down and he looked
at it.
And I said, "you know, a $35
Raspberry Pi by the time it gets
to the Brazilian market costs 150 US
dollars." And this completely negates why you
invited you invented the Raspberry Pi in
the first place.
You want a very cheap computer that
any high school student could afford to
have.
And, you know, in Brazil, it's just
not happening.
So why don't we manufacture the Raspberry
Pi in Brazil?
We license it from you.
It's a cooperative manufacturing.
And it would be a lot cheaper
because you don't have this huge customs
duty for shipping that you have to
pay.
So we partnered with the University of
So Paulo on that.
They have a surface mount technology line
and they have the expertise to do
this.
And we spent two years making these
baking 10 Raspberry Pies to show the
Raspberry Pi Foundation.
And after the two years, they said,
no, we're not going to let you
do this.
So I at that point, I had
known of a little company in China,
Shenzhen, China, named Le Maker.
And I had met them at Seabit.
I had helped them become involved in
Seabit.
And they said, well, we have a
wonderful little system called the guitar.
And what we can do is you
can license the guitar from us and
manufacture the guitar in Brazil.
So we started doing that.
And there was a lot of work
to be done and re-engineering and stuff
on the guitar that eventually became known
as the Labrador.
That we are now ready to manufacture
and sell in Brazil, which is a
little little computer, much like the Raspberry
Pi.
Except it has two boards to it.
One board has the CPU, the GPU
and all the high speed components.
And the other board has the connectors
like USB connectors and HDMI connectors on
it.
So we're doing this in Brazil.
We also have a tiny little computer
about the size of a US quarter.
And it has a M4, ARM M4
microcontroller on it.
It is used to gather data, heat,
light, humidity, vibration, things like that.
And that's another one that we're producing.
We call that the Pulga because it's
a tiny little computer.
We were going to call it the
Chihuahua, but we realized that not everybody
likes Chihuahuas.
So So we call it the Pulga,
which is Portuguese for flea, because all
dogs have fleas.
And that's another one that we're producing.
Now, you, of course, need software to
put on top of this.
We chose the Debian operating system.
But then we said, well, how are
people going to use this?
Because I will say something to you
that's very strange.
People do not buy software.
They do not buy hardware.
They buy solutions to a problem.
And maybe the problem is a game
with somebody.
And computers, you can play the game
over the Internet with somebody.
So you buy the computer to play
the game.
But playing the game is a problem
you want to solve.
So we realized that not everybody is
buying a Labrador or a Pulga.
What they're buying is a component that
they're going to use to solve a
problem.
And so we started creating mega solutions
to problems that can be handled with
the Labrador and the Pulga.
As an example, during COVID, there was
a huge demand for respirators in the
world.
And a respirator used in the university,
used in a hospital to help you
breathe, usually cost between 15 and 30,000
U.S.
dollars.
So we developed a respirator that uses
a Pulga and a Labrador.
It does the same thing for $2,000.
And so instead of buying one $15,000
respirator, you could buy seven $2,000 respirators.
And that is an example of a
solution that is created using these computers.
And we have other solutions that could
be sold.
You're about to ask me about Project
Calwan.
Exactly.
So there's another problem.
Throughout Latin America, federal and state universities,
like in a lot of European countries,
federal and state universities are free of
tuition for qualified students.
If you work hard, you study hard
in high school, you pass the entrance
exams, you can get into the university
and you do not pay any tuition.
The problem is you still have fees
and expenses.
So you have to have a room
and food while you're going to university.
You need Internet while you're going to
university..You have to buy books when you're
going to university.
You You need to buy computers if
you're going to university.
You need all these things.
And if your family is very poor,
they may not be able to afford
these things for you.
And so 40% of the students who
qualify for a free university education cannot
accept it.
Or if they do, they have to
work these jobs like flipping hamburgers at
McDonald's or being a clerk at a
hotel at night, which do not pay
very much.
And so I developed this concept of
taking students who may have been using
computers since the age of eight.
They are the people in their family
that everybody comes to when they have
a problem with their computer.
I can't install my application on Android.
Can you help me?
Oh, I can't receive email.
My Wi-Fi isn't working.
Can you help me?
And these young people will say, sure,
I'll help you because it's family.
But then when they go to get
compensated for their time, they can't ask
their mother to pay them for the
time.
Because it's their mother.
She fed them when they were young.
It's their diaper.
How can you ask your mother to
pay you for your time and expertise?
And the answer is you can't.
However, I will teach them that they
can ask a business person for that.
Because a business person needs their computer
and a business person realizes that their
computer isn't working.
It's going to cost them time and
money.
So Project Calwan teaches these young students
how to set up their own business.
And how to take the knowledge that
they already have and sell that to
small business people who need that expertise.
And this will generate enough money doing
part-time work that will pay their expenses
for them to go to university.
And therefore not getting the richest students,
but we're getting the best students.
And it's students who will be doing
work that is related to what they
want to learn in university.
Not flipping hamburgers or being a night
clerk at a hotel.
So currently I am setting up pilots
of this in Argentina, in Brazil.
And once those pilots are successful, which
I'm sure they will be, then we
will open it up to the rest
of the world.
And this project is free of charge
to the students.
They don't pay anything for it, ever.
There's no tricks to it.
They'll just be able to find out
how to do this and do it.
So hopefully we'll be able to generate
one to two million new systems administrators
and programmers using free and open source
software who know how to run their
own business.
So instead of creating one company that
has a million employees, I'm going to
create a million companies that have one
employee.
And use open software, of course.
They don't have to.
I mean, if they want to try
and do this stuff with Microsoft or
with Oracle or any closed source proprietary
software, that's fine.
My interest is in getting them to
be able to afford that university education
if they want it.
With LPI, I show them how they
can get an education, can learn on
their own.
And, you know, that's what LPI does.
But some students don't work that way.
Some students have to go through the
curriculum of a university.
And I want to be able to
make sure that they can afford to
do that.
You know, it's interesting that in Latin
America, oftentimes the oldest child does not
go to university.
Because that child has been working since
the age of 15 to help to
support the family.
So their younger siblings go to university
and the oldest one does not.
There's another interesting thing.
When I went to Cuba, yes, communist
Cuba, horrible communist Cuba.
If you get into their university for
computer science, not only is your tuition
free, but they provide the room and
board for the students.
They buy the computers needed by the
students.
They buy the books needed by the
And under certain circumstances, if they feel
that the family needs the money to
keep going, they will send a small
stipend back to the family.
So the students can be free to
learn at the university.
We can't even get our administrators in
the United States to allow a reasonably
priced college education.
This is what causes the anger in
me to build.
So if you look retrospectively, your life.
One.
What are the achievements in a few
words?
The promotion, I think number one would
be the promotion of free and open
source software.
And I must admit that in the
early days, I tended more with open
source.
I'm one of the people credited with
pointing the term open source.
But over the years, I think more
along the lines of Richard Stallman, that
free software is a better way to
go.
And it's ironic that they call open
source open source licenses.
Not restrictive and the G.
Drift of license.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Open source is permissive licenses.
And the GPL is a restrictive license.
But, you know, I look at the
GPL as being one that frees more
people to be able to have the
needs solved rather than the so-called permissive
licenses of MIT, BSD, and things like
that.
So pushing free software, you're trying to
get more people to use it.
That's definitely one.
And secondly, I think teaching at Hartford
State Technical College and later on Merrimack
College and Daniel Webster College was definitely
high points of my life.
Then, not necessarily the last, is my
husband Uku.
And who I love very much.
As far as I can tell, he
loves me.
So that is obviously something.
And I wish I had met him
earlier.
And I wish that I hadn't lived
so many years alone.
But if that had happened, I might
not have traveled as much.
I might not have met as many
people.
So it's always hard to second guess
what your life would have been.
And you can spend the rest of
your life second guessing and saying what
if.
But it does no good because we
are where we are.
If I was to have a suggestion
to young people, I would say, save
money.
You know, try to save as much
as you can.
And then as you get older, you'll
have money to do things like take
nice trips and stuff like that.
So, you know, I am financially I'm
OK, but I'm not Bill Gates.
And I'm certainly not Elon Musk or
any of those people.
So if you look at the future,
what do you think are the biggest
challenges and opportunities for the free and
open source software movement in the next
10 years?
Well, as I said, I think one
of the biggest opportunities is to take
not only free software, but open hardware
and open culture represented by things like
Creative Commons and putting them together into
solutions that people can not only use
but expand to meet their needs.
I can show people where closed source
software is actually limiting in the type
of solutions we can have because they
are not you know, the companies that
control the closed source software do not
see enough of a business opportunity to
implement what people need.
And this means that some people can't
get the solution that they need to
solve their problem.
But with open source, it puts that
back and free software, it puts that
control back in the hands of the
end user.
It becomes the end user's decision where
they spend the money with the time
or the energy to make the change
to the software that gives them a
better solution or do they live with
the solution the way it is?
And the thing is, that's the control
that they have with free software.
They still may not spend the money.
They still may not have that solution.
But that's their business decision and not
the business decision of Microsoft or Oracle.
I know that this is not a
very politically correct thing to say in
this day and age.
But I think that people have a
hard time understanding what freedom is.
Certainly, a political party in the United
States is really having a hard time
with embracing freedom.
And people have a hard time with
freedom because with freedom, you go about
your life, you say, yes, I'm free,
I'm free, I'm free.
But we're not really free.
We're controlled by all sorts of things.
So while people talk about free software,
I instead talk about the opposite, which
is software slavery.
Because people are able to envision what
a slave is.
And it's not very nice.
When you're a slave, you're told where
to go, what to do, when to
marry, when to have children, when to
work, when to eat.
You own nothing.
You're in control of nothing.
You are a slave.
And when you're a software slave, you're
told where to buy your software, how
much you're going to pay for it,
what computer system you're going to put
it on, how many people can use
it, when you're going to upgrade, how
much you have to pay to maintain
it, so forth and so on.
And that is software slavery.
And software slavery also precipitates software piracy.
When you can't afford the software, but
you need to have it to do
your business, then you put a patch
in your eye, you go RRR, and
you steal the software because you need
it for your business.
So software freedom is being able to
pull the software down, change to meet
your needs, and therefore be able to
do what you have to do for
your business or your life.
And it becomes you who is in
control, not some company.
So I realize it's not a very
political thing, and I certainly don't want
to represent the fact that not having
my laptop as the equivalent of being
a slave in the 1800s.
But there's a lot of parallels that
I think need to be said.
Thank you.
So is there anything you would like
to add that we haven't covered today?
Yeah, I would say, you know, you
asked me about things to look at
in the near future.
I would say RISC-V technology, which is
a new architecture that's coming out, is
being co-developed by lots of different companies.
It's very, very interesting, and people should
look at that as an alternative to
ARM or Intel or AMD or other
technologies.
Certainly security is very strong.
We need to have, you know, because
of the Internet and the number of
bad people out there, we need to
really work hard to have a secure
system.
And you need to plan security architected
from the ground up, not just try
and put it on afterwards.
And of course, artificial intelligence.
There's a lot of people who are
worried about chatGPT and open AI as
perhaps replacing them as programmers.
And I have no answer for that,
because I do believe that sometime in
the future, we will be able to
have what I call inorganic intelligence.
That will be just as good and
just as strong as organic intelligence.
But I believe that's a little ways
away, because what we see right now
is not really intelligence.
It is a what they call a
large language module, large language programming.
And it's the same as what the
human mind does.
It's orders of magnitude off in computing
power from what the human mind can
do.
So, you know, but the way you
get around that is that you practice
and you learn that when artificial artificial
intelligence comes in and does the low
level stuff, you still have a job
of doing the high level stuff.
You still have a job in teaching
the inorganic intelligence, what to do.
So that's about it, I guess.
A quick, quick, quick question that I
didn't have the chance to ask you
earlier.
This is my historian.
I I mean, my historian's guilt briefly.
If you want to say very, very
brief, briefly, what are your memories?
Because you said you met them of
Grace Hopper and of Morris Wilkes.
Well, both of those people were actually
hired by Digital Equipment Corporation, the company
I worked for, to be ambassadors to
go around to universities and give talks
about what they were doing.
And actually, Grace Mary Hopper was also
used, well, I think both of them
were used as advisors to some of
our, some of our engineers in digital
themselves, because many people think of Grace
Mary Hopper as somebody who went around
and gave nice talks about things like
that, but she was actually a very,
very knowledgeable, brilliant mathematician and logician.
And it's always easier when you are
standing here today and you look back,
you say, of course people understand, of
course it could be done.
But when you're back there and you're
trying to look forward, it's very hard.
And people laughed at Grace Mary Hopper
when she said, I think we can
program computers, not just in the ones
and zeros, but in English like languages.
They laugh.
And then she did a couple of
the simple compilers, Flomatic, and then became
the project lead on Cobalt.
But beyond that, she was also a
brilliant leader.
And she would take young infants and
try and get them to think outside
the box.
And I was lucky enough to have
met her at deck.
And I asked her to come and
talk at Meramec College where I was
teaching that night.
And she did.
And we went out to dinner together
and she gave everybody nanoseconds and things
like that.
So she was just a delightful person.
Dr.
Wilkes Digital had a computer museum in
some of its buildings in Marlboro, Massachusetts.
And it was unusual because they not
only had deck equipment there, but they
also had equipment or pictures of equipment
or things like that of other computer
companies.
They weren't trying to get the image
that it's only deck that had done
this, you know, they gave credit to
other companies.
So I had a young friend of
mine who was studying electrical engineering at
a university close to where I was
working and living.
And I said, "Joe, how would you
like to go to this museum on
a Saturday?
You know, we'll go inside and I'll
show you around this equipment because a
lot of this I had worked on."
So he said yes.
He was about I guess he was
about 21 at the time and I
was probably about 35.
We show up t-shirts and shorts.
It's a hot summer day.
We signed in and we're assigned a
guide to take us around.
And he was a funny little old
man and he had a suit and
a white shirt and a top over
the summer and work glasses.
And he was kind of chubby and
he started taking us around.
And he was a great guide because
he would talk as if he knew
all these people.
He had actually worked on these projects
and these were great friends.
He'd gone out to beer with them
and stuff.
He'd tell us stuff.
And Joe and I just kept laughing
about this because, no, this is a
great guide.
He made it seem personal and everything.
And we get in front of this
huge picture on the wall.
It shows this young man, maybe in
his early 20s, screwing together aluminum pipes
that are going to hold mercury, which
is going to be the memory of
this first stored program computer.
Yes, the mercury delay lines.
Yes, exactly.
And the voice behind us says, yes,
there I am.
That's me.
And Joe and I look down at
the corner and it says, Dr.
Maurice Wilkes, head of the EDZAC project.
And we turn around and his pin
says, Maurice Wilkes.
And I go, oh, my God, oh,
my God, oh, my God, Dr.
Wilkes, please, please come to my university,
come to my college and give a
talk about anything you want to.
So he graciously accepted.
We gave a great talk, you know,
of the work he was still doing
at that age.
And we went out to dinner and
I gave him four wine glasses with
the university's name engraved into them.
And he almost broke into tears because
all of his wine glasses have been
broken on the trip from England to
the United States.
And he and his wife had no
wine glasses to use for their wine.
So he was he was grateful for
that.
Now, that was the end with Dr.
Wilkes for a while.
But then many years later, a friend
of mine who had worked on the
Alpha Linux project, he had done the
boot later called boot loader called Milo.
This name is David Rustling.
And David Rustling left deck, went on
to work for Arm, became an arm
fellow, then started a organization called Linaro
that helps to put Linux on arm
products.
He was a chief technical officer of
that.
One day, Dave was asked to go
to the University of Cambridge and give
a talk about Linux and open source
software and everything about that.
He does that.
He's given a talk.
And this is old man in the
front row with all white hair asking
questions.
And David is answering these questions.
As the talk is over and everybody's
walking out, Dave turns to one of
the people on the stage and says,
"Who is that old man asking those
questions?" And says, "oh, that's Dr.
Wilkes." And Dave goes, "Oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
my God.
I've been presenting about Linux in front
of Dr.
Wilkes." So these are the types of
people that I've been lucky enough to
meet over the years and people who
I greatly respect.
And unfortunately, Dr.
Wilkes is dead.
And so is Dr.
Hopper.
But I still talk about them and
from time to time dedicate my talks
to these people so that other people
don't forget about them.
Thank you very much.
You're welcome.
It's been a real pleasure talking to
you today.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
And if you come up with any
other things you want to talk about,
you know, I'd be happy to schedule
another one of these.
So maybe we can think about.